all right so we had a question
um
and I think is important again I don't I
don't think you guys understand it
enough for the Core Concepts so it seems
basic but it's it's really
something you need to know beforehand
okay
so you're looking
at Jiu Jitsu Tactical architectures
and based on
prior Silk Road culture you know you
have yin yang Theory and if you study
the discourses that developed yin yang
Theory you have a concept that soft
overcomes hard and so uh you're going to
constantly see uh in all from all of the
Masters down to osensei including uh
generals tacticians such as Sun Tzu
you're going to see the notion that you
yield you yield to that okay
till you start having all the Arts they
have a yielding concept that they
utilize because the truth that these
people figured out is that soft
overcomes hard no one is going to invent
an art in light of that truth whereas if
someone goes no no no heart overcomes
soft that's not how they do it okay so
by the time you get to Japanese martial
arts you have this you Building Concept
in as we would say in modern times the
in all of the Jiu Jitsu which would
include Aikido as well okay
um there's a yielding so if you reverse
engineer that means the attacker is uh
doing some energy that requires the
yielding so the attacker has to have
some degree of penetration in which you
would yield to that or turn right that
kind of stuff so
um we call that in English we call that
spinal displacement okay
um so if Tristan comes up
spinal displacement
is a human behavior
that stems from territoriality okay so
if this is somebody that I'm trying to
intimidate
I will practice territoriality on him so
right now where his spine is standing in
space
in order for me to intimidate him I
would attempt to occupy that space long
before I did any kind of violent stuff
okay so this is what colloquially we say
so they got in my space you see if I may
never go hey hey you it does it's
not going to be intimidating especially
if I'm walking backwards do you see it's
not going to do it but if I'm walking
into his face you can see he smiled he
inhaled all that stuff because he
thought I'm going to push through that
space do you see that okay so just
psychologically human beings that want
to intimidate another human being will
practice territoriality if you're
unfamiliar with this you probably do it
if you have a child or you have a pet
when it's time to discipline your child
or pet you never walk away from them get
off the couch get off your couch your
dog knows that he doesn't really mean it
but you start walking
the dog goes whoa and the dog get out of
there okay human beings are no different
so it's a type of territoriality uh it
it is such though
that there is uh a sociological tie to a
social violence because it also
tactically allows for two major
strategic objectives one is take his
base compromise his base and support get
him get his balance and his posture to
be compromised okay so for example if
I'm here and I'm just kissing the
surface of this his posture is not
affected at all but if I go and I take
this spine in space and occupy it with
my jam boom you can see that it gets him
on his heels and going backwards it's
hard to change directions when you're
going One Direction and it's hard to uh
get a counter attack going when you're
on your heels so it leads to that and we
call this in modern time times a
violence of action so you see a lot of
people that assault human beings they
intuitively just use violence of action
but you also see it in certain military
strategy or law enforcement strategy
where it's all let's go go go go go and
you get as much Firepower in to where
you need it as fast as possible you
catch the person uh off guard unable to
launch a counter-offensive okay
so I'm trying to intimidate displace and
get my violence of action going by
compromising his posture okay and I
cannot do that
when I'm out here I cannot do it I
cannot do it
also
when he has weapons
and I know he has weapons so let's say
he's law enforcement and I can see taser
baton OC handgun
I'm not going to go out here
because he's just going to have time to
draw his weapons but if I launch on him
it's very hard for him to draw those
weapons meaning I am getting close
enough and imply and applying enough
pressure that he can't bring those
weapons into the fight so there's a
strategic advantage in regards to that
same thing goes when it comes to his uh
pugilistic weapons
so for out here again final stance I
gotta fight all of this stuff and Bob
and weave and yada yada yada even if he
didn't have time to draw a knife okay
what people will do is just crash
through all of that okay so he's gonna
try to pop me in the face oh no I don't
care I'm not gonna do that I'm just
gonna go in here
faction and now I'd start whatever
offense I want to do
all that is spinal displacement
but if you understand it in terms of Yin
and John
while it looks pretty cool it looks like
it'll function it's functioning because
he stayed still that's why it functions
okay so for example he's charging me as
fast as he can it looks like oh that's
good he's gonna take that four Aikido
guy down
but if I don't yawn here he goes and
then
you see so that's where your Jiu Jitsu
comes in don't contest
that okay
it's very common in a social violence
which is why people that study only
Aikido keyhon
will say that kihon works and you go
well what do you where did it work well
oh I work at a psychiatric hospital or I
work at a prison or something like that
or I work in law enforcement because
that's always going to be a social
violence so people are going to
penetrate territorially and try to
displace my spine and your kihon is all
geared towards that kind of attack okay
inversely if he's throwing Jabs to my
face without any commitment right back
in and out and I'm going to try to do
coachage no no you're not because I did
a turning move
a Yin move he did not do a young move
that's incorrect that does not work okay
so you'll see people he's jabbing
jabbing and they're like oh I'm gonna
follow it in this is stupid
that did everything that I might have
wanted to do by making a fetish out of
gas do you see that so he didn't have a
spinal displacement and that jab is
gonna work that job will work use the
jab okay so I'm going to show you a
couple things
um
let's get in a stance that you want okay
and uh you'll throw a rear cross just on
my
body okay
so here I am not with spinal
displacement and he goes you're gonna
hit me when I get in the range of that
cross oh man that's a heavy hand okay
now without even going fast I just keep
moving throw it like you mean it I just
keep moving
the strike is smoother the timing gets
off it goes into his wrist
Etc that's why people that are asocially
attacking someone they just run in or
like we saw the gray season in the 80s
and 90s they smothered people took away
their ballistic options and those people
had no idea what to do after they got
the Gap closed on okay
um let's say
he's trying to do his his uh
you come in
right like he's doing his slow grabbing
and he's going to come in and grab me
well here's where I just throw those
stripes at him okay I don't have to spy
with this place either I just keep
moving he moves boom
but if he runs at me and I try my
strikes it's not gonna work
so strikes
and your nagiwaza
are not
substitutionary you they don't work in
the same place okay which is why when he
throws his jab I don't follow this back
in so I can do good lagash this is done
this is not yin yang okay likewise
he throws his jab I don't go like this
for any other that is also done that's
not where the technique fits okay
um so what I want you to do in this
drill is you're just going to charge
lead okay and on one person I won't move
go as fast as you can athletic boom okay
and then on the next rep
he goes
okay we're gonna yield we're gonna get
out of the way okay let's try so you can
feel when it works and when it knocks so
let me give you the third one okay on
your third wide
you're gonna run in here when he's
running at you
you run the heart at me maybe you're
gonna feel all young you've got even
stronger okay all right let's try it
okay now now you're going to do the same
thing
so what are we tuning one meter one
meter okay
you can even get ready if you want okay
and he's gonna run at me as hard as you
can nope I need you to be more hardcore
today
okay
get on one meter
go
[Music]
then
half a meter
okay
okay try it okay
now at one meter
get on the line
I want you not to displace my spine
do you understand so go slow so I make
sure you understand what I'm what I'm
saying
I'm saying good so you pulled me in okay
so now you're going to do that as fast
as you can
[Music]
I'm trying to get
I'm trying to yield that's his same
little tank on that worked magically
before
now we'll go to half a meter
okay and if it's as fast you can without
penetrating my spine go
and same thing you can see we start
contesting okay
um
now go back to a meter
and without
displacing my spine just like the first
one go
the strikes open up you see
same thing
half a meter don't displace he goes
let's see are you here
okay that's where you use them so if
there's no spinal displacement your
strikes are going to be there
he's basically mimicking the heavy bag
the heavy bag never displaces your spine
okay if if we invented a heavy bag that
would continually displace your spine it
wouldn't that wouldn't work okay it has
to not displace
so you can see where it works so in this
drill that's what he's going to do one
meter without spinal displacement half a
meter without spinal displacement you'll
try your Yin moves okay go
okay he says the true attacker the true
Asus a social Salter the rapist the
domestic violent half uh the murderer
the The Knockout game person those
people are doing asocial violence they
will practice that territoriality and
they will finally displace okay the
other one is the street smart tactician
they are going to try to do violence of
actions so they're going to try to do
that displacement to get you on your
heels compromise your posture and make
you have to defend yourself
um or the uh hire a tactician knows I
don't want that dude drawing a weapon so
they're going to close that fast okay
now uh the person that is dueling in the
bar
probably won't
probably it's very common that they're
not going to do that that's where you
start seeing the doing tactics of like
sport competition right so I don't
really want to kill him or anything and
more importantly I just don't want to
lose
it generates a whole different
psychology where you have a lot of
self-detection in there uh so much so
that you don't understand violence of
action where you're just going to go
balls to the wall and get that guy on
his heels okay so if I'm dueling or as
far even when you know a sparring you're
not going to get any of your keyhonawaza
architectures there they're that's not
where they go okay but that's where all
your strikes go and stuff like that or
that's where all your weapon draws go
do you get it says he he didn't close on
me now I'm drawing my knife I'm drawing
my hand again you see that's where that
falls into play okay
that's exhibit a
exhibit B
is
I don't want to ever be in these little
hypothetical half a meter thing okay I
don't want to do that
so you're in your
whatever and he's trying to hit me then
we're in I'm in a half meter again do
you see that that's wrong so let's say
he's gonna do Sho manucci okay so he's
gonna step through and cut down my head
see go back
so here I am he goes and I'm at a half
meter but that's La La Land
as he so let's go back to half meter go
back to half meter okay
uh I'm reading his body that's how I'm
gonna get out of the way of this thing
or how I'm gonna get those strikes okay
so uh you're gonna go as fast as you can
there he goes you can do whatever attack
you want I don't care but okay so when I
read his body he goes and that is where
I can attack him uh as fast as he's
attacking me if I can't read his body
then I'm gonna get my strikes smothered
etc etc okay so same thing here when
we're doing striking I'm never going to
sit here and he's going to get he's like
one meter away he's gonna get a half a
meter before I move that's not going to
happen Okay so you can do whatever
strike you want and you're gonna see
that when he gets a beat on me I'm
already moving I'm not going to pretend
that people attack from way out there
but you'll see that I get him way out
there because when he gets a beat I'm
already moving
[Music]
foreign
and that's what will happen
they'll throw things out of range
or the Duelist will start trying to get
closer
and run at you because they can't hit
you okay so let's say
we're doing the Aikido
strikes
we'll stick with show manucci right as
soon as he has his beat I'm already
moving
if he throws it out of range
to me trying to hit me
here
follow your target I'll do it
you see
here goes
there it is
we'll go again
good and again
good and again so notice how he's now
spinal displacing he's overshooting me
can you see it
he died he's not stopping here
he's passing me as he's trying to hit me
don't you get off in space
do you end up
in Eagle but let's do that again
he's a little off balance
going this way
he touches
there it is
not like this
hello
nor with that little reach to my head
just reach my head
now
you make him mess up
boom there it is
look where he struck
where's his balance here
here it's not yield there it is
alright so you're gonna get out of the
way
and you're going to try to keep getting
them let's go
okay I can't remember if I said or not
but that last drill is I can make a do
list finally displaced see by how I'm
moving
how do you move
don't let him don't wait until he's
throwing the strike
you already are moving when he has the
intention
when he has the attention you're already
moving that makes him move
when I move to his intention I always
move
to start the fight rotating
so I can only move at this corner
this corner
back isn't going to do anything for me
okay so as he gets to B I'm already
moving
another way you can frustrate the
Duelist into spinal displacement ish you
make him pay for Bridging the Gap too
slowly okay so you might have for
example I'll do it
okay I'm doing my attack I'm gonna wait
until I get close enough
you see but that's where oh I'm not
spinal displacing that's where the
strikes come in
so he's trying to get close boom and
I'll keep him out
combine that with my movement
you're gonna get a guy to get very
frustrated but
okay so now we'll combine
where the only way he's getting in there
is he's got to go for it okay but I'm
never aware he needs me to be where he
goes for it making this very common
striking response in Aikido
incorrect you see how different that is
okay
try